this is a production of Cornell
University
okay hi everyone welcome to a 2023 hem
webinar series my name is
PhD student implementing and genetics in
larisman's lab at corner University and
once again I'm a company by Tony baraco
Cornell alum who has estimate with
equipment series as well as Gemma and
Kim who have provided this digital
platform for us the webinar series
lastly I just want to mention that this
webinar series is a component of a
larger project which is the development
of educational modules that will be
freely available on the Canelo Pam
website at the end of the webinar series
each module will have the recorded
webinar the instructional slide egg and
a set of high impact papers pertaining
to the respective subject for instance
for this subject or for this module that
will be on ham Harvest
all webinars and recordings of them will
be available on the Cornell sips YouTube
channel
um so if you're interested to rewatch
into watching them or sharing them with
somebody else according attend on
specific dates
uh so with that it is my pleasure to
introduce different Philpot he is a
Marine Corps veteran in a current
um environmental biological science
career Research Chicago State University
and his talk today is going to be on
cannabis glandular trichom relevance to
harvest so with that Steve please stick
it away
um always yeah uh thank you for the
introduction I appreciate that
um thank you to Cornell for hosting this
platform and uh for being featured among
the other featured speakers
um awesome so today uh I'm going to be
talking about cannabis glandular
trichomes I know a lot of us have heard
of them and are familiar with them kind
of as a more broad topic but I just want
to kind of talk more about
um these glandular trichomes why they're
relevant to harvest kind of the
information that we know now some of the
information that's coming out and then
um kind of want to talk about some of my
work and why it may uh you know be
relevant to uh
any producers that are cultivating
floral cannabis and we'll kind of talk
about some of those differences
um to dive straight in
so everybody's kind of familiar with a
lot of the policy but I just want to
make it clear
um all of the when I say Cannabis used
in my research at all was federally
compliant hemp these were all state
approved hemp cultivars um so one of the
reasons that we kind of um obviously had
to use hemp is because of the DEA
schedule and status and we did not have
a license so
um just want to make that clear but I do
kind of want to talk about some of the
discrepancies
um because this is relevant to Farmers
that are looking to
um kind of learn more about harvesting
um the DEA schedule one status kind of
changes a lot of our ability to do
research on obviously hemp and Drug type
or or above 0.3 percent THC cannabis
marijuana
um the research gridlock as I call it is
kind of a contradiction that has kind of
slowed down research for a while the DEA
has a scheduled saying that there's no
current medical uses but the FDA has
already approved of you know multiple
drugs
um and when we go to policy we hear a
lot of times that more research is
needed so
um I hope that although this is about
floral help it can kind of be understood
as more of a an overall topic uh on
floral cannabis as well
um one of the reasons being is because
this is uh I took this from the USDA
plants database classification report of
um and this was kind of how the
classifications of uh hemp and marijuana
are specified or classified
um on a more taxonomical uh basis so you
can see the genus it says um you know uh
Cannabis sativa L it has its marijuana
but it also has hemp above that
um and then as you move further down to
these subspecies you see there's
Cannabis sativa L sub species sativa
Cannabis sativa L subspecies indica and
I realize that this naming uh issue
becomes difficult for Farmers
um who are looking to find this kind of
data that's specific to something that
is more applicable to their end use
all that to say
um you know two of the biggest issues
when we hear things like sativa and
indica
um there are some vast assumptions that
go along with this and this is kind of
what's relevant to harvest
um I have experience working in a retail
setting and that's kind of what got me
interested to really jump into the
research
um we would get cultivars with the same
name but the actual metabolite profile
which is what floral cannabis is
typically sold for
um it varied vastly every different time
batch to batch and for you know people
who are medical uh consumers you know
sometimes they would have different
effects so this was very important that
we needed to look more into the
consistency of the production of these
metabolite profiles sometimes there
would be little to no terpenes sometimes
the cannabinoids themselves would be
um you know vastly different the reason
I bring all that up is because a lot of
the assumptions when you go to a retail
setting
um they're classified as a sativa
or in Indica
um and I think most of us know at this
point that um those terms don't uh
necessarily correlate to the metabolites
that are responsible for the effects
that these titles have claimed
um so the reason that I say all this is
because the inheritance principles like
the basic principles for genetics that
wasn't something that was published
until
1865 and Carl Anderson John Baptiste
Lamarck actually made these designations
of indica and sativa way prior to that
um so all that to say these terms are
are being used incorrectly in retail
settings when it comes to being able to
describe the metabolites
um that the product is being sold for
um so what are the big problems uh some
of the biggest problems I'd say are a
lack of federal best management
practices if you look up most common
crops in your region you can find some
type of best management practices based
on your soil uh makeup based on your pH
based on kind of your little
microclimate where you live
um and with cannabis it's very difficult
because you don't find this information
publicly although there are more
research projects obviously coming up
with agronomic data for local farmers
and that's why we're doing things like
this
um
I say that to say that for cultivation
Harvest host Harvest and storage
um there is not a lot of research uh
diving into trichomes and necessarily
how the trichome density or quantity
affect the metabolites um to take kind
of like a 300 foot view to take a step
back we base the legality off of
cannabis plants right hemp is below 0.3
percent THC marijuana is considered
above 0.3 THC these arbitrary
definitions aren't necessarily
benefiting cannabis cultivators who are
cultivating for floral uh hemp who want
to remain compliant
um so long story short this is really
what got me interested the industry
standard of trichome analysis is most
people are familiar with you either have
a light microscope a Jeweler's Loop a
magnifying glass
um there's typically just a visual
analysis of you know these trichomes
look clear cloudy or Amber those are
typically the three
um
excuse me those are typically the three
kind of physical features that people
are looking for when they're looking at
what people might say rightness
um although that may help that is a very
subjective means of analyzing what the
actual cannabinoid concentration is at
what point are you at risk for being
non-compliant at what point are you uh
should you harvest based on what you
want you know uh people say 70 cloud or
30 Amber these are all very subjective
uh means of analysis and kind of passing
those on
um just makes it even more subjective so
long story short I got very very
interested in trichomes
um and another means of analyzing them
kind of on a deeper scale
um
the lack of insight into factors
affecting secondary metabolite
production meaning pre and post-harvest
again we're looking at these trichomes
kind of with the naked eye or with the
magnifying glass but that is a lot
different than actually homogenizing
that sample mixing it with the solvents
running it through some type of
chromatography machine and getting the
cannabinoid concentrations
um another issue with that is how cost
effective is that for Farmers to do that
regularly can they test that week one
two three four can they test regularly
and how consistent are these tests
um so that's again another risk of
compliance
um and then long story short this entire
industry is driven Now by retail uh
mostly even though there are still
medical consumers and the demand for
quality products
is kind of an issue right now because if
you look at a lot of farmers they're
struggling financially because there's a
surplus and products but the quality
kind of across the board Across the
Nation as we rapidly legalize isn't
keeping up um with this kind of Rapid
mass production of cannabis so
um that's all we're talking about
trichomes and how they relate to artists
very simple uh most people know the
basic life cycles of cannabis
um you have your seed right seedling
excuse me or your clone if you decide to
start with the propagation
um during this phase the plant is
spending most of its energy and
resources right establishing its roots
um during its vegetative stage once you
start seeing rapid and and uh consistent
growth and development of roots and
shoots
um you kind of have this Vegeta
vegetative growth going on but flowering
is kind of what I want to talk about
today because when we're talking about
cannabis that's harvested for
cannabinoid rich or terpene-rich biomass
we're talking about harvesting flowers
that's also really important because a
lot of policy
um kind of groups in fiber cannabis
grain cannabis CU cannabis and even
non-flowering cannabis into the same
group and from what we know right in the
literature is that this flowering stage
is when these metabolites start
producing and when we start seeing these
trichomes that we're talking about
um so this is one of my favorite images
and I want to kind of take a second to
break it down
um when we say we're looking at
trichomes we're talking about these
epidermal growth so we're talking about
what people would say uh makes cannabis
look Frosty or shimmery or or shiny
um there's these resin field glands that
grow during flowering that provide
protection to the outer layer of the
plant what's really really interesting
about these is that
um they rapidly rapidly increase in
their growth and development during
flowering
um but we don't necessarily know how
they exactly contribute to the
cannabinoid concentrations that we're
seeing in the test it's a lot different
to test uh you know maybe something
called kief which is isolated trichomes
versus testing an entire uh like a
picture a here what we call an entire
complete inflorescence where there's
stalks there's leaves there's flowers
and maybe not all of these pieces have
the same coverage of trichomes meaning
that they potentially have different
metabolites
um even in in locations that are close
to each other uh image B is one
individual calyx underneath the light
microscope
um it's actually the Brack that's
covering the calyx if you look at the
very top you can see these orange
um
style that are protruding out that would
catch pollen on a live plant
um if it was to be pollinated like most
of us know lower cannabis we typically
don't right we don't want it pollinated
so those seeds produce we want those
trichomes to continue producing
secondary metabolites until whatever
point the cultivator or farmer decides
hey this is when I want to go ahead and
harvest
um MHC is what I've actually analyzed in
my research so most of the time when we
do testing it's uh we say we homogenize
the sample right so we kind of take that
sample a uh with the leaves with the
stalks and also with the calyx and we
would kind of crush it all together and
we would analyze that sample what's
really interesting is something that you
know is already in other research is
that
the trichomes the glandular trichomes
don't develop at the same density or
quantity at every location and if you
look at MHC it's pretty easy to tell
that
um
if you look at the red arrow that's
going to be a bracket so that's what's
actually that protective specialized
Leaf that's covering that calyx and then
if you look in this really really
trichome dense area
um and when we're talking about
trichomes you'll be able to notice them
obviously because of these circular
heads they almost don't fit in they look
very intentionally built but this this
this section where the uh
excuse me where the Green Arrow is
pointing is covered in glandular
trichomes and that's going to be our
calyx and then if you look over to the
right the blue is actually the base of
again that what you see is that orange
stigma sticking out in it and that the
image B and the image D is going to be
uh zoomed in this is really where I do a
lot of my work so that I can look at the
morphological differences between
different trichomes
um I'll start with this yellow arrow at
the top on image D all the way to the
right that's going to be a non-glandular
trichome so these trichomes don't uh
produce secondary metabolites these
trichomes are more of a physical barrier
honestly I like to think of them as a if
you ever see they put the spikes on top
of a doorways sometimes so so birds
don't just hang out there I like to
think of those non-glandular trichomes
as these physical barriers
um whereas this red arrow this blue
arrow and this green arrow these are all
glandular trichomes and we're going to
talk about the different types of
glandular trichomes of the differences
and things of that nature but these
trichomes are where the secondary
metabolites are produced and I really
want to take a second so everybody we
all know this but sometimes we rush past
it
um a lot of this floral or biomass
material when we're when we're running
tests when we're actually analyzing for
cannabinoid concentrations we're not
necessarily looking for that most of us
if you if you think about it we're
looking to quantify uh the metabolites
that are produced and stored in the
glandular heads
um of these
um glandular trichomes the red arrow is
going to be a South glandular trichome
the word before the glandular is usually
what tells you where the position is or
the morphology so stocks glandular
trichome is self-explanatory there's a
large stock that actually raises the
glandular head above the surface you'll
see Cecile glandular trichomes which can
be similar or close to the same size as
soft glandular trichomes
um the difference is that sessile
actually means like resting sessile
similar to when you think sessile think
like a barnacle on a whale or or stuck
to the shore right so these are
glandular heads that are resting
directly on top of the surface
um and then the third type and the
Lesser known the less research type is a
bulbous glandular trichomes which is
really really small uh trichomes
um again just to kind of go over what I
just said
um this is an image that has artificial
coloring just to make it a little easier
to process the differences
um again if you look at this uh red
arrow over here you're going to have
this style again which would catch
pollen if you were breeding or open
pollination
um to pollinate this female cannabis
plant you have your green arrow here
which is your non-glandular trichome
those physical barriers
um yellow being these short bulbous
trichomes and then this blue arrow again
a Cecile glandular trichome
um the biggest difference between these
glandular trichomes which produce
metabolites
um within each other is they have
specialized cells that are made for the
synthesis and the storage of these
metabolites so again to kind of make
this relevant
um these glandular trichomes they were
looking at this is where we are finding
the highest concentrations of
cannabinoids terpenes inflatanoids
um what's really interesting about the
differences is the gland size is the
first thing that you you can obviously
see sessile and stock glandular
trichomes can have similar sized head
while bulbous trichomes are much much
smaller the actual cell count in the
head of the gland and then obviously
weather has a stalk or no stalk just
strictly applied to stock tarantula
trichomes one other interesting thing
that's come out in research is that
there is a uh monoterpine succoturping
difference between Cecile glandular
trichomes and uh stock glandular
trichomes with stock range or trichomes
having a more mono terpene dominant
profile and set Sidewinder Electronics
having more sensile glands or sessile or
sesquil terpene dominant profile
um
again what's really important before we
kind of move into the research is the
the purpose of these trichomes is not to
produce for you as a human uh the
purpose is for this living organism
which is a sexually mature female plant
awaiting reproduction of pollination to
produce these molecules
um in response to their environment
based on you know combination of
genetics nutrients and environment but
that doesn't always mean that every part
of the plant is doing this evenly or
even you know consistently so
something that was really interesting uh
I was an Adjunct professor at a
community college and it was really
interesting to kind of teach the natural
morphology of cannabis plants I think
you hear so many trimming and training
techniques that people forget cannabis
kind of naturally grows like a Christmas
tree and not literally but
um obviously it's wider at the bottom
and then it's more narrow at the top
focusing most of its energy at the top
or apical meristem where a circle is Dr
Bernstein said something really awesome
last week and I'm glad she kind of said
it and I want to preface that is that
um she said a tomato plant you know all
the tomatoes are kind of going to get
chopped up and put in a salad so at one
point you know you harvest when you
harvest but I was curious on cannabis
plants how different could these
trichomes be
affecting possibly the cbda
concentration within the same plant but
just the different locations so that's
kind of the basis of uh some of my work
um so I'm just gonna take you all
through
um kind of where I am in my work so far
um and then you all can ask any
questions at the end
uh so the hypothesis of my work is
essentially to check the quantity or
density and I'll explain the difference
between those of trichomes and um my
guess is that trichomes will vary
significantly across different parts of
the plant just because even if it's you
know one node at the bottom that's maybe
in the shade of another one or that was
kind of my guess
um and then cbda concentrations uh being
compared to those quantities and is
there any type of correlation between
that
um or are we just seeing differences
that maybe are attributed to something
else that we're not measuring
um when I say local variation or sample
location you'll see a one two and three
um these just refer to the apical
meristem or the tallest flowering node
um 50 of that node's height so 50 of the
the tallest flowering though and then
the lowest flowering node that I could
collect uh two tenths um
two tenths of a sample from so two tips
of a gram
uh so we had seven cultivars there were
eight but they died um they were all
grown in a uh federally compliant uh
State licensed Greenhouse facility
um all samples were harvested at week
nine of flowering uh and again what we
did was analyze the tallest flowering
though the uh half of that height and
then the lowest flowering note and two
samples were collected at each location
just to kind of see if there were
massive differences
um the cultivars were intentionally
anonymized the reason that I did this is
because
um for people who maybe don't understand
the processing or the extraction I don't
want to uh
either have my research manipulated or
misrepresent uh maybe the trichome
density all these of these different
cultivars because again growing in
different environments it could show you
know a totally different expression of
metabolites tricodicity things of that
nature
uh so our the research layout was
on-site floral custom analysis so as
soon as I showed up
um and actually measured and marked this
top middle and bottom of this plant I
went ahead and ran uh cannabinoid
analysis I'll talk about that in a
second
um I also collected uh samples from each
location took them back to the
laboratory immediately and dissected the
floors floral clusters looking for one
individual calyx kind of at the most
distal part of the uh branch of that
node that I collected
um those individual calypsies were fixed
to a brass tub and imaged under sem
there were two different fix fixation
methods that we used so methanol ethanol
fixation as well as liquid nitrogen just
to kind of compare
um and I'll talk about why we did that
those images were uploaded to msj where
I manually have been counting trichomes
for the last I'm not sure how many
months
um but that data was then calculated
against the calyx length width and area
uh to create a density metric and then
um data tab was used in Excel to kind of
do our statistical analysis
um we are still working but I do kind of
want to run you all through where we are
in the research so my three main aims
the first one again uh to compare
methanol ethanol fixation of liquid
nitrogen the reason behind this is
methanol ethanol is a tradition it's a
more traditional plant fixative method
um the issue with this is anybody who
kind of knows how they make uh made old
medicine or how they make what's called
tinctures as soon as I heard methanol
ethanol I was like oh I think that
that's going to cause that's an
extraction essentially
um so I wanted to compare traditional uh
fixative methods and when I say fixative
I mean the scanning electron microscope
that I use operates within a vacuum and
this vacuum
samples that contain water
um will kind of just be distorted when
this vacuum occurs so
prior to actually Imaging in the sem the
samples either need to be dehydrated or
fixed or uh some something that'll keep
them stable and safe so they can image
be imaged inside the machine uh aim two
was to use cryo sem to image
individually dissected calyx and then uh
aim three was to analyze floral clusters
so uh again the same size sample from
each of these clusters that you see in
the picture and this is uh one of the
best examples that I have these are all
from the same plant same cultivar but
they were collected from different
locations and just at First Sight when
you look at them um visually there's
obviously you know you can see
differences
um in between those three different
locations
uh
uh and aim three was to analyze those
floral cluster samples so to actually
take that again Analyze That metabolite
concentration and then compare it to the
density to see if there was any type of
correlation at all
um just so I don't lead you all alone
we're not finished so I don't have the
answers for you today
um but I did want to update you all on
kind of how this applies to harvest and
where we're going uh so A1 was methanol
ethanol fixation uh the image over to
the left is what it looks like prior to
actually being inserted into the
scanning electron microscope uh this was
soaked in methanol for 10 minutes
switched back to uh ethanol and then
back to methanol one time
um and it was treated with a critical
point dryer so you can even see just
looking at it um it doesn't really have
any green color to it anymore
um but it is again the most common and
traditional way to uh image uh plant
samples in a scanning electron
microscope
the other method that we prepared was
using liquid nitrogen so you can see I
have a liquid nitrogen tank here this is
a cold resistant Bowl which we pour the
liquid nitrogen directly into
a leaf or plant sample is fixed to a
brass tub and then we actually dip it in
that liquid nitrogen it equivalent it
equilibrates Bubbles as a sample is uh
it's cooling and then once it actually
stops bubbling that was just kind of our
consistent we take it out of the liquid
nitrogen once it stops bubbling
um that's kind of a really quick time
limit after that where you have to drop
this brass piece into the silver holding
piece and insert it into the electron
microscope
um
this Leaf I don't want anybody to think
I'm being fake this Leaf is not a
cannabis leaf um this Leaf is actually
from I think it's traditionally called a
Cuban oregano which is not the
appropriate name for it but that's it's
more well-known name
um and it is a plant that is rich in
terpene so I was very interested because
I used to walk by it every day in the
greenhouse and kind of rub my hand on it
and I would smell that this smells
lemony
um and I got very interested talking to
my thesis advisor I said hey you know if
there's terpenes being produced in this
other plant maybe instead of wasting
hemp samples uh while I'm still trying
to learn these methods I can use another
plan and really test out and see how
well
um this method Works to use liquid
nitrogen image so
um this is actually the image of that if
you see this video over here to the left
so this is the surface of what I just
showed you
and this is what it would look like
under an electron microscope essentially
um
taking that and increasing that
resolution and that magnification all
the way down
so the surface
whenever I'm doing this work I always
wonder you know where Dr Seuss got a lot
of his ideas from
um and I say that jokingly but something
that's really interesting is uh sorry I
wanted to pause that
um something that's really interesting
is if you look at the uniformity under
here uh it almost looks like it it's
built in a very specific way so that's
why I got curious about density
um and the actual accounts and why there
are differences why are there bulbous
trichomes right here and why is there a
stock trichome right next to it um again
this isn't in a cannabis sample but I
use this as a proxy essentially or a
practice
um to get the methodology down because
like I said
um sem is kind of an art form I've met a
lot of people who do it but I realized
everybody does it a little differently
and I found out that this methodology
worked really well for um some of the
images that I was trying to take
um so uh liquid nitrogen versus uh
methanol ethanol so these two images the
image over to the left is going to be
the liquid nitrogen sample that was
prepared
um from a cannabis plant and uh the
image to the right is going to be
methanol ethanol prepared image
so the pros and cons are really what we
were looking at in this aim to see hey
should we use the traditional fixative
method of methanol ethanol preparation
or should we use liquid nitrogen and go
you know more cryo-sem
um so what we noticed was very obviously
if you look over to the right um
comparing the pictures the some of the
glandular trichomes over these heads
that um in the image over to the left
you'll see they not a perfect sphere but
again the morphology is is very uh
distinctive from the image to the right
where the only way I can really describe
it is it looks kind of like a uh
balloons have been deflated right so the
whole purpose of this is to try to
preserve the natural profile uh all the
images all the images that we took were
from samples that were not dried they
were not cured they were taken from live
uh cannabis plants and that's one of the
first things that really stood out to me
over here to the left if the trichomes
are what are producing these metabolites
and we're typically distorting these
trichomes whether it be drying curing
things of that nature
um the image over to the left that we
use liquid nitrogen seem to give us
really high resolution pictures with not
a lot of distortion or kind of warping I
will be transparent and say the biggest
difference is when you use liquid
nitrogen your your sample is destroyed
in the process there is no way to pull
it out analyze it later or do anything
else with it
um when you use methanol ethanol that
that that sample is actually able to be
stored
um in a controlled environment and then
use it again later
so for our research we use liquid
nitrogen the reason that I brought up
what I just said is the industry
standard for floral cannabis again we're
talking about harvesting is to air dry
process prior to processing and
packaging uh I got really curious in the
process of using liquid nitrogen and
methanol ethanol and was thinking hey if
the most common way is neither one of
these you know prior to processing or or
or anyone consuming it or whatever it's
being used for
we're typically drawing we understand
that there's decarboxylation going on
but I don't hear much conversation about
what's going on with the morphology of
the trichome so
um this is kind of an extreme case we
just left this out in a room
um at room temperature I didn't put it
in a like a climate control
um kind of box or anything or in a room
where we control the climate I was
curious just to see it two weeks just on
the counter kind of what the differences
would be
um and these SCM images show again
um not the same as that methanol ethanol
or that solvent based fixation but you
can see
um this kind of distortion of the
glandular heads again they look like
deflated balloons and even if you look
at the floor or the the base uh where
these trichomes are you can kind of see
almost this it almost looks wrinkled or
kind of shriveled
uh aim2 was the image quantification so
once these images were taken from each
of these locations
um the area was actually calculated for
each image if you look at this image on
the bottom we actually use the scale bar
and image J to set the ratio so that the
scale bar in the bottom right hand
corner of the image this set
um
where is it
on the bottom right at 500 micrometers
that we were actually able to relate
that to a pixel ratio so that way we
were able to analyze
um the not only the glandular count but
the calyx length width and the density
which we used area
um
like the image in the upper left hand
corner to calculate
thanks
excuse me
um also for sample analysis for the
glandular trichome count
um I left some of these undone I know
somebody's going to say it doesn't look
like they've all been counted once you
count all of these and you Circle each
one manually it becomes a very dense uh
picture to look at and you can't really
see what's underneath so you can see
there's still some bulbous glandular
trichomes that are visible kind of in
the middle of that picture but each of
those red dots represents a glandular
trichome that I manually went ahead and
counted
um using msj software
uh and then aim three uh kind of you
know uh compare a lot of these
differences and there's a ton of
different variables that I share
um really really close to being finished
but I don't want to share prematurely
but
um looking at this picture in the upper
left hand corner again this is the same
thing
um if you look from I believe let's see
left to right
um each of these rows represent a
different cultivar and samples collected
from again the apical meristem 50 of
that apical meristem height and then the
lowest flowering note
um two tenths of a gram of each kind of
floral cluster or inflorescence was
homogenized and combined with 30
milliliters uh methanol agitated for
five to eight minutes and then four
milliliters of the sample was injected
um into the light Lab 3 Portable
chromatography device and that is how we
calculated the cbda concentration live
um as soon as we remove these uh floral
clusters
one thing I want to give a disclaimer
for I don't want anyone to be upset at
me
um I don't want anybody to think that I
am boosting my cbda numbers I actually
did this on purpose because this is one
of the biggest questions in the industry
is when we see tests when we see the
cannabinoid concentrations the terpene
concentration what is being represented
there
um so I got really interested in looking
at
calyx that was the primary basis I
didn't want leaves and I didn't want
stems because I was Imaging isolated
calyx with all those other parts removed
I decided to isolate and only test
um the cannabinoid concentration of
Calyx since these are where the highest
density of glandular trichomes
um are resting so this image right here
again shows two tenths of a gram of the
same sample from the same plant on the
same branch and you can kind of make the
Assumption right from what most of us
know that these two samples tested uh
differently and it's because again if
some of these leaves and some of these
stems have a lower trichome density you
would expect that the concentration of
metabolites would be lower
um so this is just a kind of uh profile
cannabinoid profile of um once you run
your actual test using the white lab so
these were actually put into my Excel
sheet and compared to tricome density
based on each location
this is just a quick picture to kind of
give you a
an idea of what it's like so this
picture all the way to the left is going
to be the cables isolated from the top
of the plant
this is the middle of the client in the
middle and then the bottom of the plant
all the way to the right so again they
were measured for width length area
trichome density and then the floral
cluster that they were sampled from was
analyzed for cbda concentration
these are all the total metrics of
analysis
um once I finish this research and um
go ahead and defend my thesis and make
it public
but I did want people to know that all
the cultivars from the same location uh
the tricome density of each cultivar so
again tricome density of say plant a at
location one two and three which would
mean the same plant at the top in the
middle of the bottom those were compared
as well as the cbda concentrations and
some of the other variables that um
we're looking at is calyx width versus
length does that have anything to do is
there a difference between the top of
the plant and the bottom of the plant
and other locations as well as area
glandular trichome cow
um and just kind of comparing all these
different variables
um just really quickly again I don't
want to spoil everything I do still have
to present this research uh to my thesis
committee but the average glandular
Trico account was something
um again one of the first things that we
actually got we counted so the bar on
the left of each sample will be the
application location one two followers
is the middle and then three being the
lower these were the count of glandular
trichomes I did not separate glandular
stocks from Cesar algo Angela from bobus
a because as the density uh increases it
becomes very difficult to even see the
bulbous glandular trichomes
um and B I wanted to make sure that we
were actually including
all trichomes that contributed to some
type of metabolite concentration
regardless of what little way shape or
form it may be
um so these are just our accounts uh in
my mind you know uh we like to think
that the plant is produced evenly that
it ripens evenly that these trichons are
going to be the highest at the top you
know uh moderate out in the middle and
the lowest at the bottom um but that's
not the case in fact it was highly
variable uh one of the things I have to
remember in research is that it's always
great if you find something but more
often than not you you won't find
anything
um and you use that research to write to
kind of build more research from that
um
so average cbda concentrations again
these are typically higher than what you
would normally see that is because all
the stems all the non-glandular uh
excuse me all the
um
the floral parts that don't don't
contain a high density of glandular
cannabinoids were removed and these are
just the calyx
um so from each location you'll see if
you look at plant sample a it's kind of
what people would typically expect
highest at the top modern in the middle
big drop at the bottom
um but there are some differences
between different cultivars and Sample F
was pretty interesting
um because the cbda concentration didn't
vary much at all
um from the top and middle and the
bottom
um
this is just a box plot of uh the length
in millimeters versus the um
oh this sorry this is the difference in
length average across each sample
um in millimeters the reason we're
looking at this is because I was curious
if each cultivar
um if there was like a normal size of
Calyx you'll see research will kind of
say there's a certain size of Calyx but
what we realized from each sample was
that they could be totally different uh
G was kind of our outlier but again
there's still more data to contribute to
this
um so preliminary conclusions kind of
from this aim and to make it applicable
for Harvest why did we do all this talk
about
um glandular trichomes
um first the results revealed that
trichomes are very sensitive and
delicate and exposing them to methanol
ethanol can dissolve them uh which makes
kind of the Imaging after that not
representative of a natural living
cannabis plants trichomes
um the sem images that were obtained
from the top and middle and the bottom
of the plant
um there's obvious differences that were
shown but we do need more research to go
ahead and be able to say there's any
type of correlations between different
locations from what we've seen so far uh
it's been vastly different different at
each spot which again has been part of
the research process but
um
the summary of these results and to make
it applicable to a farmer uh or anyone
who's cultivating there are so many
factors that go into trichomes I have to
take a step back afterwards and consider
what else might be at play if we're
looking at the same plant which is the
same genetics this isn't a clone this is
the exact same plant so where is this
variability coming in the play if we're
using the same testing device the same
methods the same solvents
um where could this variability kind of
come into play and these are kind of
some of the things for Farmers to think
about
um the genetic potential right what what
kind of mother plant is it where are you
getting your genetics from are you going
to be pollinating that plant to get seed
or are you taking colognes from that
plant the seed stage we have to think
about environments and nutrients along
with the genetics from that mother plant
so is there some type of epigenetic
effect on trichomes where uh where
possibly the environment is affecting
this expression of different metabolites
even in very subtle ways on the same
plant and
to consider that you know we're really
looking at this glandular trichome
production in Floral cannabis in these
uh sexually mature female cannabis
plants only once they are unpollinated
and they continue to swell and increase
their cannabinoid concentrations
the opinionative method that's been used
traditionally is that clear cloud and
Amber clear cloudy and Amber are the
subjective means which we use with the
naked eye or a low magnification
um Imaging device to analyze these
trichomes but those don't give uh
concrete insight into something that can
protect the farmer from cultivating a
federally non-compliant uh floral
cannabis plant
um also to take into consideration that
trichomes are not only sensitive
um you know afterwards but they're
sensitive on the plan as well so
pre-harvest and post-harvest the
environment that it's exposed to whether
it's a dry room whether it's in an
airtight device whether it's exposed to
humidity all these things can affect the
cannabinoid concentration and
essentially make it look like you have a
different metabolite profile prior to
you harvesting and analyzing just with
your naked eye and then you analyzing
that sample two or three weeks after it
has sit in a certain environment
um and again we saw that trichome
degradation when uh with the air dry
samples
um and then compound analysis what we're
saying is cbda concentration what
material is represented in the sample is
being tested kind of those two images
that I show world are we looking
strictly at the most dense parts are we
looking at the kind of whole
inflorescence
um and that kind of you know that's a
long Rabbit Hole to talk about and
compliance and testing and things of
that nature
um and then it's the post-harvest
environment affecting these trichomes
and the secondary metabolite quality we
know about decarboxylation but we don't
often talk about the actual quality of
the trichomes post Harvest
um I'd like to thank my advisor Dr Ghana
I'd like to thank my committee Dr
Maselli and Dr Earhart
um thank you to the core facilities at
Chicago State University for keeping
that electron microscope working uh
during all these hot summers and power
outages and different difficulties
um and then thank you to Orange
photonics for allowing me to use the
light Lab 3 Portable cannabis analyzer
for uh field sampling
and thank you to Cornell University for
having me as a feature speaker for this
webinar series
presentation Steve thank you so much
thank you thank you let me see so let's
uh
there's three q a
have you tried using an environmental
scanning electron microscope they allow
viewing of living materials UIUC has one
in their microscopy facility if you want
to try I have not I would love to try
um I've learned a lot about kind of the
differences in electron microscopes and
that was one of the things that we
didn't have access to
um but yes that is kind of the path that
we're trying to start this conversation
instead of us always looking at the
metabolite concentrations of a cannabis
plant that's been harvested and is no
longer alive why don't we start looking
more into the inside of these uh these
organisms while they're still living so
uh great question
uh did you see any structural variation
in trichome samples collected from
different locations
and environment between the genotypes
um so we didn't do any we didn't do any
genotyping each cultivar that we looked
at if that's what you're asking
um yes we did see differences in each
cultivar but it was so vastly different
that
um
you know again I think something that
would have been amazing right this
amazing breakthrough would have been if
we found out yeah there's an even
difference between the top the middle
and the bottom there's this kind of
gradual gradient of trichomes but no
there was definitely structural
differences
um in the morphology and the density at
the same within the same plant at
different locations
um but yeah if that's what you mean by
genotypes
um I'll get an eliminated time and
budget
what would you want to research yeah so
I would like to do a genetic component
to that uh whether it's epigenetics
genetics genomics just because we now
have insight to kind of this
um
the genes that go into thca synthase and
cbda synthase and I think even knowing
that and knowing uh that we can test
these genetics we're still finding out
that there's this variability right this
uh plasticity if you want to call it
um we know that because cologne's grown
in different environments
um are obviously vastly different so
that's kind of something if I had an
unlimited budget and cloudy versus clear
and harvest
half clear I'm guessing you're asking me
my opinion
um
I I guess that's the whole point of my
research in this talk is that it's so
subjective right um I've even when I've
been working with cultivators and
Farmers I've asked them you know 70 30
60 40 and they'll say it's different for
every cultivar because they are using
their nose and they are using their eyes
and they're kind of some of them have a
really good technique down
um some of them you know they realize
that hey sometimes we do have to destroy
our crops because they're non-compliant
because maybe one plant that looks you
know 60 40 is okay but maybe another
plant that 60 40 becomes non-compliant
so
um hello has a few questions Peter oh
Peter that's a couple questions all
right
um what other issues do you believe how
much time do we have Louise
uh
it's supposed to end at 3 P.M but if
there are many questions and we need to
cover them all we can extend that for a
little bit oh we got 12 minutes right
okay
um ask your questions to ask you what
other issues do you believe persist in
the Cannabis industry with regards to
its growing preparation or consistency
as both business owner and researcher
um what are the topics are still fresh
for research in regards to cannabis and
health what has your experience been as
a plant science researcher focusing on
cannabis any difficulties in approval
finding information sources grants
anything unexpected
um yes that's why I started with the DEA
schedule one status that is obviously
prohibitive
um to a lot of research that we're
trying to do are there any fresh topics
everything
um I think that's why we're here and
it's not a novel field but we're diving
back into something Humanity kind of
took away from themselves during
prohibition what other issues do you
believe persist in the Cannabis industry
um I think that as
each state begins to legalize I think if
you go immediately to indoor cultivation
and mass production
um you take away this kind of uh
environmental parameters that have been
used to get us to the
um kind of genetics that we have now
these local microclimates appellations
terroir if you will
um that have the effect on how these
plants are cultivated so I think one
thing is to consider you know these
environments and how much they do affect
um cannabis plants and like I tell
people you know Florida and California
both grow oranges
um but you know they grow them for
particularly different reasons so I
think we'll get more into a regionality
more microclimates
um maybe an heirloom hopefully
um kind of overhanging that covers uh
those kind of quote-unquote Legacy
Farmers if you will can you discuss the
optimal environments in which to store
cannabis post Harvest to produce
degradation of desirable compounds yeah
so again this is and I hate giving
people the it depends answer but it
really does depend even just in the
structure of the actual bud itself
um that could change the actual airflow
that you need so you have really really
dense floral clusters where they're kind
of overlapping on each other as they're
drying and curing that may require more
airflow than something that is kind of
more
I hate using that right the traditional
what we consider sativa morphology or
more leggy or more spread out
um
Peter asked another question what do you
recommend based on your experience to
those getting interested in cannabis
research
um find a topic you're passionate in and
be patient and learn your local policy
because what I can do in Illinois is not
the same as what Louise can do in New
York is not the same as what you know
people can do in different states so I
think that's really really important
find something you're interested in and
then learn your local legislation is
there any possibility of trichomes
changing from one form to the other with
time yeah so uh this is kind of one of
the like kind of groundbreaking
researches that's out there it's not
mine I don't want to take credit it's a
Sam Livingston in Canada he actually had
a project where he compared sessile
glandular trichomes to stomach glandular
trichomes and and checking the actual
transcriptome because they have
different metabolites that they're
producing one is more Cesspool terpene
one is more monoterpine well the
transcriptome isn't different they don't
seem like they're any different but but
they are producing different
metabolites so the thought processes
that possibly sessile glandular
trichomes would be precursors to stock
the glandular trichomes which makes a
lot of sense they're the same size and
literally what we realized is
morphologically nobody technically has a
classification between the two when the
sessile becomes stalked like how far
above the surface does it have to be
flat on the surface can it be raised a
little bit because there's some sessile
glands or trichomes that sometimes are
just above the surface is that going to
keep developing into something that's
right raised above the surface or not so
definitely a possibility and that's kind
of where the research is right now
that's why we need to learn more because
we honestly don't know
have you looked at or know any
correlations between tricome production
and viruses we've seen in cannabis
plants
um so that is where I'm hoping that we
get I'm hoping that when we look at some
of these plants that are more
um I use powdery mildew for for kind of
an easy example is there a cannabis
plant that is uh better at being more
resistant to powdery mildew okay is
there some type of genetic component in
there got you now from there does that
have anything to do with the trichome
differences is there any type of
metabolite differences uh or is it just
something totally unrelated so great
question this is kind of why you know I
tell people when we're really talking
about cannabis most of us are only
talking about glandular trichomes we're
only talking about the metabolites that
are produced you know we kind of leave
seed and fiber and grain
um the really really you know big
potential Industries we leave them out
but I think if we're going to continue
talking about floral cannabis and
increasing its supply chain across the
country country I think we need more of
an agronomic uh plant science focused
rather than you know traditionally uh
cannabis research would have been more
drug focused um so I think there may be
one more are you aware of any research
that indicates the optimal environment
has to draw into the cameras such as
temperature humidity and gases content
of the air
I will send Louise some research after
this that's going to be available
um it's not my research but there is
research that has different opinions on
optimal environment but again I think
that's one of the beautiful things about
this if I say the optimal environment to
drive the optimal environment to drive
what cultivar at what age was it
harvested what is the floral
architecture literally does the airflow
make a difference is this one more prone
to Bud rot because its floral
architecture is Tighter and denser so I
don't want to avoid your question but I
also don't want to be misleading because
I think we have a lot of people online
as experts kind of saying this is the
absolute best way to do it and you
should only do it with the knees
parameters and I think what people
should do is start harvesting small
samples of your plants and you should
start testing them in a kind of a linear
fashion and we tested it at 40 humidity
50 humidity 60 humidity and we looked at
the content you know afterwards we
looked at the trichomes we looked at the
cannabinoid concentration and then you
make your own kind of In-House research
and development because that's what we
need you right now
oh I got another one
all right
can you compare indoor versus outdoor
production of trichomes is it different
um
so the research is that based on so
again the purpose of these trichomes
right think about it they're
Environmental
excuse me they're environmental
protectors whether it be the
non-glandular the physical barriers or
the glandular that are these kind of
chemical bio factories that are
essentially extending from the plant
surface
um so the research that I've seen there
is a major difference between the type
of radiation or light spectrum that it's
exposed to so UV radiation or shorter
wavelength higher energy radiation
um seems to increase the production of
trichomes which you know theoretically
if you could take you know the same
cultivar clone it put one indoor one
outdoor if you could measure that um you
know if you if you can measure that par
radiation if
you know for lack of better words
um and compare those two I'm sure you
would see some type of differences but
you know
again it's so different in each
different cultivar so
uh
I got all 11 out the way is there
anything else in the chat
yeah so thank you so much for your
presentation Steve it was a great
presentation and thank you for answering
all these questions and pretty sure that
the audience
is pleased that we were able to get to
all the questions
uh well thank you so much everyone thank
you Steve once again
um
please join us next in the in two weeks
actually for our last webinar
um it'll be on May 3rd and this will be
focused on hemp processing extraction
and testing by Jamila lamalfa Donaldson
from
average with University I believe uh how
you pronounce it so
yeah
thank you so much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu